what's weird to me is Satan hey guys i'm
ryan right and i'm gerry so people have
been asking us to do a little video
about the Aquaman suit
my initial thoughts it looked cool I
wish there was more color to it because
Aquaman has like the yellow sure the
green and stuff and they kind of just
went like Viking status which makes
sense let's tell like a maori warriors
and yeah it looks like it would be a
merman I mean which is cool adjust it is
way different I'm not entirely sure how
I feel about whatever this guy's name
Jason move Jason Momoa I know I've seen
him before he's in Conan that he took
over for Arnold keys and Game of Thrones
and he was in bullet to the head I don't
find him to be the greatest of actors
okay he's charming short I mean the last
thing i've seen some a game of thrones
and the last thing I saw him in was
[ __ ] Conan and I thought he's pretty
bad well you should try Lee hued act I
just didn't really buy him I mean he's
got the perfect bill for it does he know
like I don't know I never I guess I'd
never associated aquaman with being like
[ __ ] ripped yeah oh look shiet cuz
this dude looks big like like Aquaman
was muscular but he didn't look like a
big dudes like a whiny ever cast the
rock as and this guy looks like he's got
a build like them rocks yeah less
shoulder mo it's normally just some like
white dude who like short blond hair so
[ __ ] yeah it's like some generic looking
why do I'm not saying you should be a
white dude I'm just saying like this guy
is giant like I'm just wondering how
because it's supposed to be he supposed
to appear in Madame steel yeah right
like every other [ __ ] superhero and
because I hear he's one of the original
founders of the Justice League so it
makes sense for Aquaman to at least make
an appearance if you want to just talk
about the suit the suit I feel is it's a
little weird to me because it doesn't
look like he's wearing a suit if you if
you go back down to that picture it
looks like that's his chest like it
looks like that's his chest and he's got
like this strap thing on that's armor
that's armor and this stuff just all
looks like tribal tattoos oh man that's
I guess it's a little green around the
forearms yeah and his right shoulder
might be just as bodies yeah just like
tribal Teddy and Aquaman could be cool
if / pulled off perfectly because
there's a whole Aquaman world there's an
Aquaman family anything can be cool if
it's perfect is it true
yeah statement I think when they do the
whole new 52 thing for DC I heard a lot
of people saying like oh they actually
made the Aquaman comics really cool
because they kind of took into account
the fact that people laugh about Aquaman
now and built that into the story so
like Aquaman at least the first issue is
constantly running into people who
aren't taking him seriously yeah but
this looks like a really serious dark
interpretation just off this photo of
Aquaman what's weird to me is you see
Superman suit a man of steel looks cool
looks like a Superman suit it's darker
but it looks like a Superman suit and
then you see Batman and it's like Dark
Knight Returns inspired and then you see
Wonder Woman how it looks enough like
Wonder Woman then you see this suit and
you're like this doesn't look like
anything obscene of aqua mezcla I don't
know this from the new updated Aquaman
or something but he looks like [ __ ]
um uh what's Arielle's dad's name Oh
Triton tryi right yeah that's who you
looks like great thick ya know he does
look like trying a little bit the photo
itself it sound me worried I mean I'm
sure I'll fit into their universe
somehow but yeah I'll make it work I'm
just a little bit like Oh interesting I
feel like Zack Snyder sometimes needs a
co-director like I feel like Zach's
honor gets so excited about the story
but but then he forgets to keep working
on it mm-hmm it's like once he's got a
cool idea and it's like written a measly
okay no no we gotta actually we gotta
get this stuff like we got to get the
rude we're gonna make the sad that we
gotta shoot it he knows how to capture
comic book worlds and they look his
visuals are always awesome and from my
understanding I've avoided the footage
because i want to see like good quality
footage but i've heard like that man has
like the white eyes and it looks really
cool so far yes so I'm sure he's gonna
deliver on the visual aspect but for him
to take over like Justice League getting
total is kind of a bummer to me when
they said I was next time he's gonna do
justice league too I was like well I
mean I'm sure he'll do a fine job like
it's like Peter Jackson returning to the
hobbit except I hope these results are
better it's like well I mean I've seen
him do this before so ok cool I would
have liked to have seen a different film
maker to make it interesting but yeah
it's like I feel like it's one thing to
keep it in the same universe but then to
keep them all kind of looking the same
the other situation you know like that's
what made Avengers work they always get
different directors from Marvel films
and then they got Joss Whedon for
Avengers yeah because they all had
different flares but Zack Snyder like I
don't know how a man of steel 2 is being
shot I don't know it's gonna be all
handheld again but yeah I mean it makes
sense but I mean he doesn't really do
handheld a lot sold man of steel I
wouldn't be surprised if Man of Steel
carried on that visual flair and maybe
justice Lee would be different like
maybe he will make them to different
movie that's when I feel free will
probably happen ya know I'm hoping that
he does provide that and I'm hoping this
Aquaman cameo Wonder Woman cameo goes
over well I'm really hoping it yeah i
hope i really hope this is meant to be
how that script is and not just like
okay we gotta get our Justice League off
the guards put [ __ ] in Man of Steel
that's all we got right now it's like
they're not understanding build up there
like all people won't as Batman and
Superman but no one really knows the
other Justice League characters so let's
just make justice league and introduce
something well the thing is like I mean
I guess you can't copy Marvel but it's
like you know before iron man came out
not a lot of people knew about Iron Man
comic who didn't otherwise you know read
them and invest in the moral universe
they might have known like basic
information yeah it's like Batman is
Superman or two characters where it's
like everybody knows this guy's like
regardless of whether you've read a
comic book or not some of these
characters are a little less known in
the cannons like mmm totally make their
own story because yeah it's like when
they came out with iron man a lot of
people who weren't comic books a beer or
like I don't know but this is rad same
thing memoria is like I don't know but
this is rad and even even Captain
America it's like you know a lot more
people know who Captain America is then
know what has stories about yeah I feel
like it would behoove you to just
actually make these movies yeah it
tomorrow however I preferred if it was
like yeah you get they get individual
movies then team up it's not as exciting
if word of introducing them like inja
it's exciting sure but at the same time
it's like I liked to have seen fully
fleshed out characters first have their
own movies and then see those characters
come together yeah not create them for
justice league yeah and I mean on the
one hand it's
a nice just to have a small sequence of
things to look forward to because the
Marvel Universe is staggering and tab
two of those would be a little
unmanageable maybe but at the same time
it almost feels like when like the
really cool big thing comes out and then
like for Christmas you get like the
slightly more knockoff Maria where
you're like oh cool it's a giant sort of
team of superhero franchise except it's
only these three movies right yeah
exactly well yeah [ __ ] it I don't know I
usually make about it so like DC's
figured out TV a lot more than they've
figured out yeah they got their TV
universes down really well people love
their TV yeah I'm either TV shows are
[ __ ] awesome like that it's great and
they know how to introduce other
characters in the DC world see like our
ra's al ghul just appeared an arrow or
the flash camera which one but we're
Gotham and got the Joker and just
appeared in Gotham I mean Gotham's the
most like split audience what I've seen
them is it yeah like amongst fans among
critics it's really good but amongst
fans there's a like a big split decision
on how they feel oh I'm sure I mean
those those it seems like those shows
always take a season or two for people
to get on board because when Arik came
out of room was like what is this and
now everyone arrow yeah watching people
seem to like flash off the bat but yeah
like arrow and Gotham I feel like her
would be similar that way Oh totally
especially it's like if you make a flash
of we're just gonna be like it's gonna
work and then they see it they're like
oh cool where's Batman Gotham like
there's so many expectations you're
gonna have to win people not just
impress them a little and they [ __ ] with
a lot of storyline and Gotham you guys
because it's like they're taking place
out of such a specific time in Gordon's
life but then people want to tune in for
the Batman aspect so they're like
introducing these villains like six
years old yeah it's like six years old
and they got these villains were like 10
years older than him and Catwoman's even
older than him and they might have been
copying Marvel a little too much if they
integrated their TV shows with the
movies I'm sure matt is still too will
be badass in in some ways it's just it's
Batman vs Superman and I don't want any
[ __ ] distractions other characters
like I just don't yeah like that's it's
[ __ ] up other Batman characters sure
Suicide Squad introductions sure cuz
it's the Batman world and it's the
Superman world but then you throw in
these other
rules and have them make cameos it looks
like the cameos are not like a
post-credit sting it sounds like they're
gonna be making cameos if I have my
concerns yeah I do too i mean i feel
like a super remove is probably a better
place to introduce characters like these
than maybe a batman movie and just
because like the superman world always
feels a bit more fantastical to me for
some reason so like I don't know there's
something about having your central hero
being superhuman where his Batman that
kind of point is like he's just a guy
with a lot of technology and some great
detective skills but I read The Dark
Knight Returns so if they honor what how
Superman about Batman fought each other
they'll be cool then I want them to make
the movie where Superman fights Cassius
Clay like on the Sun or whatever you see
that that old comic book so famous we're
like Superman and catches but I have a
boxing match yeah and like they go
somewhere where their powers are matched
they put on Krypton that's right I think
I think Holly wins yeah and they should
do Batman vs predator they tried it
tries comics they tried making something
else in that oh they did a short film
with Batman oh yeah that you're gonna vs
alien ports alien vs predator and batman
just somehow gets caught in the center
of it i have some comics that are vs
predator and i don't know what they're
they might just be aliens I think they
did terminator vs Man 2 yeah they should
start doing that shoes crossover a movie
studios should just go bananas yeah I
can like go all out there crossovers
then Robert Rodriguez a neill blomkamp
have to team up for new aliens vs new
predators yeah and then they should
throw an antonio banderas there's el
Mariachi yeah this collide so many world
yeah the neo from the matrix and then
Colin Farrell from phone booths Lady
Gaga Lady Gaga disc then Cuba Gooding
jr. from Jerry Maguire yeah like
negative not having making Jack
Nicholson for wag the dog he's on in my
boo dog hey totally minded uh that's
Robert De Niro Dustin Hoffman are you
sure wag the dog oh good just guessing
it's good as it yeah yeah which is Jack
Nicholson beam jack nichols yeah they
should have like Al Pacino De Niro Pesci
Harvey Keitel Ray Liotta is
a good interest of robot didn't
Nicholson yeah all being a superhero
film they should play the older version
of the Justice League you know what I
think they should do they should get
Tyrone Magnus to play Aquaman i watch
that movie I would watch it too yeah
because there are no rules like like
there are no rules dictating that
Aquaman has to be a white dude so yeah
like please yeah there are a lot of
white dude super milas beer here there
are a lot of white dude superheroes that
don't need to be going dude so here they
might be going with miles for a
spiderman which would be great I can do
it finally like make us worth our while
anyway guys thanks for tuning in thank
you and mentioning this photo was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects jerry has
a show on this channel called reasons
Jerry check that [ __ ] out doggy we could
have a whole video about who could play
Peter Parker if he wasn't just Peter
Parker I'm telling you Al Pacino with
great power comes great responsibility I
want to see your spider-man movie where
Al Pacino played his Uncle Ben no I
think Robert general play uncle then
it's for Ben Stiller spider-man doesn't
meet the Paris